breaking overnight US stocks look set
for a sharply lower open amid growing
fears over the coronavirus and in South
Korea a frequent visitor to a US
military base has tested positive for
the disease South Korea is one of
multiple countries where coronavirus
infections have skyrocketed ramie
Inocencio visited that military base in
Daegu near the epicenter of the South
Korean outbreak here in South Korea city
of tegu the country's fourth biggest
crota virus cases have quadrupled since
Friday empty streets have become the new
normal for the city of two and a half
million residents tako is also home to
more than 2,500 US military servicemen
and women CBS News was granted access to
the US Army Garrison here with
temperature screenings and the same
questions for all visitors everybody and
today a first for the US military in
Korea a 61 year old woman linked to an
American soldier at this base has now
tested positive for coronavirus Colonel
Edward Blanco is the face of the base
giving health and personnel updates on
Facebook live on a personal level how
are you feeling with the situation
outside I'm nervous but I feel confident
too
the corona virus is really harsh on
people who are vulnerable our population
regular relative to the regular
population is not vulnerable still
though I you know I we're all nervous
about it meanwhile in the US people are
protesting against plans to quarantine
patients in California and Alabama from
the virus chicken Diamond Princess
cruise ship anchored in Yokohama Japan
the Trump administration backed off
plans for Alabama but is confident in
the country's response to a potential
outbreak
[Music]
and here in Daegu this city is basically
under a state of emergency but not under
an official lockdown well at least not
yet
as for the capital Seoul the government
is under increasing pressure for example
the Parliament building has now been
shut for its first time in history
that's after a man who is now confirmed
to have the coronavirus walk through its
doors last week
Tony Ramey innocencio in Daegu South
Korea ramie thank you very much